bonsoir à tous soyez les bienvenus dans
votre journal de l'afrique à la une de
l'actualité le départ des forces
françaises et européennes du mali face à
la menace terroriste paris avait déployé
ses hommes il ya neuf ans le calendrier
de ce retrait reste à préciser on y
viendra avec bakary a semblé notre
invité dans cette édition
au coeur de l'action sera non plus mali
et le niger emmanuel ma croix confirme
un repositionnement des soldes dans le
pays sauf que l'avenue ses troupes
étrangères est vue avec méfiance vous
entendrez quelques réactions et puis le
continent attire les investisseurs du
moyen-orient 300 entreprises émirati
sont aujourd'hui implantées en afrique
elles fleurissent dans différents
secteurs celui des énergies
renouvelables en particulier
reportage au togo à la fin de cette
édition
pas de réaction devant la presse mais un
simple communiqué dans lequel le pouvoir
en place à bamako se dit prêt à
travailler avec tous les partenaires
disposés à sécuriser et le mali
l'invitation ne concerne que les états
européens membres de la force takouba
alors même que ce groupement se prépare
à quitter le territoire au même titre
que barkan le rappel des faits avec axel
ciment
le départ de l'armée française du mali
est confirmée véritable casse tête
logistique le retrait s'étalera sur une
durée de quatre à six mois d'après le
président de la république
il sera effectuée de manière ordonnée
avec les forces armées maliennes et avec
la mission des nations unies au mali
durant cette période nous maintiendrons
nos missions de soutien au profit de la
minus mans concrètement les trois bases
de gao gossip et ménaka seront donc vidé
soit 2400 soldats français de
l'opération barkan qui participe depuis
2014 à la trappe des groupes jihadistes
dans le sahel au delà de barkan le
retrait français va également entraîner
la fin des forces spéciales takouba créé
il y a moins de deux ans les militaires
européens y participant seront
repositionnées dans la région
frontalière du mali
avec l'accord des autorités nigériennes
des éléments européens seront
repositionnées haut côté des forces
armées nigériennes dans la région
frontalière du mali
paris réaffirme toutefois vouloir rester
engagé avec les européens auprès des
pays sahéliens et du golfe de guinée
pour poursuivre la lutte contre le
terrorisme aux côtés du président
ghanéen et du conseil européen le
président sénégalais présents à la
conférence de presse a indiqué
comprendre la décision française nous
avons convenu avec l'euro que la lutte
conte le serbe contre le terrorisme en
hausse elles ne seraient être la seule à
faible depuis africains et labsus un
consensus
que un engagement a été renouvelée de
rester dans la région et de les
articuler le dispositif paris a promis
de coordonner son retrait non seulement
avec la mission de l'onu au mali la
minus ma mais aussi avec la mission de
formation de l'union européenne au mali
le utm qui continueront de bénéficier
d'un soutien aérien et médical français
sur place avant le transfert ultérieur
et définitive de ses moyens
bamako la capitale certains considèrent
maintenant qu'il revient aux forces
armées maliennes de prendre le relais et
couvrir tout le territoire à d'autres
sont en revanche plus sceptique la
correspondance influent l'espion à
bamako l'annoncé du retrait de marquer
n'était une surprise pour personne des
annonces qui était attendu et même
souhaité par une large partie de la
population malienne qui dénoncent
l'enlisement de l'armée française neuf
ans après le début de son intervention
au mali une armée qui n'a pas réussi à
fournir une réponse à la crise
sécuritaire d'autres au sein de la
classe politique d'opposition s'inquiète
de l'isolément du pays un pays pivot au
coeur du sahel qui a besoin je cite de
tous ses fils et de tous ses partenaires
je vous propose d'écouter l'un des
membres du cadre des changes sur les
potentielles conséquences du vide laissé
par barkan sur le plan sécuritaire ce
qui est à craindre c'est que les
dialyses demain ne se regroupent et
trouver un boulevard devant deux pour
envoyer le nord et le et le centre du
mali où ils sont déjà tapis disséminés
dans les populations je pense qu'ils se
le groupe pas parce qu'il ya cette fois
c'est cette présence étrangère qui est
dissuasive demain avec le départ mais
force d'appoint et bar quand est-ce
qu'ils vont pas se grouper pour envoyer
le mali et s'ils le font c'est ce que
l'armée malienne aujourd'hui a les
moyens de les allaiter de les contrer
des forces de sécurité qui oeuvrait
jusqu alors aux côtés de l'armée
française déployés dans le nord du mali
quels seront les impacts sur les
populations qui sont régulièrement
ciblés par les groupes djihadistes qui
s'affrontent dans la zone pour cet
habitant de gao dont nous avons décidé
de protéger l'identité pour des raisons
de sécurité l'heure est à l'incertitude
les principaux prises depuis la crise
avec
des discussions
en vide qui pose également la question
de l'engagement sur le terrain des
autres partenaires internationaux dont
la mission de maintien de la paix au
mali qui bénéficie de l'appui de barkan
en cas de problème des partenaires qui
font régulièrement l'objet d'attaqués
sur le terrain il y en a justement
s'intéresser à l'avenir sur le terrain
entre autres avec vous bakary sambe
bonsoir à vous êtes le directeur
régional du team big two institute à
dakar merci d'avoir accepté l'invitation
de france 24 alors un tout à l'heure
pendant la conférence de presse qui
avait suivi l'annoncé officielle de ce
départ des forces françaises europe et
emmanuel macron récusé le terme d'échec
est ce qu'il est dans le déni la halle
président français ce qu'il n'y a pas
tout de même un échec relatif
oui vous savez la difficulté pour la
france au sahel j'ai tout le temps de
devoir gérer l'urgence et l'histoire en
même temps c'est vrai que c'est un
engagement français qui s'est fait sous
pression et qui finit d'ailleurs sous
pression a été
sur un plan communicationnel mal
d'encadrer et je pense qu'il ya eu tout
le temps ce conflit de perception du
conflit sahélien entre les populations
locales et les acteurs internationaux
je pense que la france véritablement
avait perdu la bataille de la
communication depuis très très longtemps
mais je crois que c'est les parents tant
qu'hôtel barkan qui est un échec mais
celle approche tournée vers le tout
sécuritaire qui est un échec parce que
le terrorisme ne se combat pas seulement
par les armes il faut s'attaquer aux
causes structurelles et on n'a pas fait
cet effort de scinder la problématique
dans deux cantons du bac la lutte contre
le terrorisme
oui qui ne l'a pas fait cet effort là
les partenaires de romain ne l'ont pas
fait mais je pense qu'aussi ils ont
entraîné dans leur sillage leurs
partenaires africains vous savez il ya
plus de vingt stratégie celle
plus de 18 de ces stratégies ont été
conçus hors du sel et sans les sahéliens
je crois qu'on n'a jamais essayé de
donner la dignité de solutions aux
stratégies endogène écouter les
populations locales et je crois que
c'est ça qui c'est qui s'est répercutée
maintenant sur la vision des populations
locales sur bar call qui je le rappelle
comme l'audi les placer le chaos joué un
rôle très important sur le plan
logistique mais aussi sur le plan
d'appui à la communauté internationale
et aux intervenants au mali les
populations à gao le témoignage que l'on
vient d'entendre notamment la personne
jointe par notre correspondante disait
que barkan rassurer la population
si je vous suis bien la prise en
considération de ces populations plus
largement dans tous le seuil est ce
qu'il y a aussi une part de
responsabilité aujourd'hui qui incombe à
la junte arrivée au pouvoir au mal y
esquisse a pu peut-être précipité ce
départ sous pression comme vous le
disiez vous même je pense qu'il faudrait
aussi partager les responsabilités
il ya toute une communication pour
dénigrer cette mission et c'est
l'intervention mais aussi c'est vrai que
cette mission a fait défaut à ses échecs
mais je pense que il est plus aisé de
critiquer l'opération barkan et critiqué
l'intervention des forces françaises et
d'autres forces européennes quand on est
avocat
quand on est confronté à l'insécurité
permanente dans ces zones
transfrontalières où les populations
vivent les conditions draconiennes des
mesures sécuritaires mais intense en
insécurité je pense qu'aujourd'hui il
arrête de sincérité s'impose je pense
que c'était excellent débattu à pau dans
un sommet précédent où il ya aussi la
difficulté la duplicité dans le discours
de certains chefs d'état africains qui
font appel à la france quand il ya des
mesures sécuritaires mais qui en même
temps au parc aux populations n'assume
pas cette coopération là et cela a
rajouté duflot au flou et je crois que
avec la désinformation qui est une
réalité quotidienne sur les réseaux
sociaux et avec l'arrivée de nouveaux
partenaires pourquoi le nommer c'est les
russes je crois que la situation s'est
dégradée en même temps que la
communication ne perdez en efficience en
tout cas on n'a jamais été efficaces
sinon on ose dire et dans tout cela nous
sommes devant une pression qui pousse
l'armée française un capitaine et un
plus bas à se retirer du mali est
injustement et à se repositionner pardon
bakary sambe ccc c'est très intéressant
tout ce que vous développez mais comme
nous sommes un peu pris par le temps je
voudrais justement vous fait réagir à
certaines réactions rhdp par nos équipes
à niamey sur la perspective de ce
déploiement de troupes dans le pays on
les écoute on se reparle
du compte toute présence militaire
étrangère
sur le territoire du niger parce que sa
menace la souveraineté nationale a forcé
barkan sincèrement nous devons tirer les
conséquences de leur présence lorsqu'il
était au mali est légion ne sont pas du
tout confiants les gens ne sont pas du
tout confiants est ce que c'est une
bonne stratégie là que de se redéployer
au niger où manifestement la population
est assez hostile à cette arrivée de la
même manière que le ps en serval avait
commencé sous la pression ce
redéploiement s'est fait sous la
pression c'est à dire je ne prends pas
qu'il y ait une stratégie pensée de
redéploiement en art ce temps c'est que
les populations traîne c'est qu'on
reproduise les mêmes erreurs de
communication qui ont conduit à tout
conflit de perception du conseil la
conception internationale et les
perceptions locale aujourd'hui c'est
beau une véritable communication de la
part des partenaires européens eux mêmes
en premier lieu la france mais aussi de
la part des partenaires africains qui
font la demande expresse vous allez
entendre le président macky sall dire
que les pensionnaires africains ne
pourront pas tous à café au terrorisme
maintenant c'est le redéploiement du
côté du niger mais aussi après bien
entendu vers les pays du golfe de guinée
qui en feront la demande si je cite les
propos des marques et des communiqués je
pense tout cela a posé d'être accompagné
une forme de pédagogie pour que non
seulement
les militaires français les partenaires
européens les partenaires africains
puissent gagner la guerre contre les
tories mais aussi la paix avec les
populations locales et avec pédagogie
merci beaucoup bas car ils sont 2 merci
pour ces éléments de compréhension
rappelle que vous êtes le directeur
régional du à tombouctou instituteur à
dacca merci à vous un mot maintenant au
sujet de notre confrère le journaliste
khaled rare ni le parquet d'alger reculs
lourds de peine à son encontre plus de
deux ans prison ferme elles les
autorités l'accusent entre autres
d'incitation attroupement non armés et
atteinte à l'unité nationale
le jugement de ce nouveau procès sera
connu 3 mars prochain khaled rare ni
couvre en fait les marches du ra qu'il
estime n'avoir fait que son travail
après avoir passé 11 mans détention il
avait été gracié par le président
tebboune en février 2021
cette image maintenant celle de
barthélémy dias s'investit à la mairie
de dakar il remportait en janvier
dernier elle est nicipal dans la
capitale sénégalaise cet opposant
farouche opposant même au président
macky sall est est prêt dit-il à tendre
la main au chef de l'état sous certaines
conditions je propose de l'écouter il
répondait aux questions des limes ndao j
invite l'état à une collaboration
sincère avec pour objectif de belles
réalisations pour l'ensemble des
dakarois je ne suis pas à la tête de la
mairie de dakar à un poste de combat
contre les institutions de l'état en
revanche je m'opposerai par tous les
moyens en ma possession à toute
tentative que pourrait faire prêter des
opposants à la libre administration des
collectivités territoriales
d'autres temps forts de ce jeudi cette
réunion au sommet à bruxelles les
dirigeants européens africains appelés à
réinventer leur partenariat quelques
heures donc après les annonces faites
depuis le palais de l'elysée au delà du
défi sécuritaire les sujets sont
nombreux l'épidémie de kovy dette une
priorité dans la mesure où seulement 6 %
de la population sur le continent
africain est entièrement vaccinées à ce
jour l'union européenne s'engage par
ailleurs à donner davantage de doses de
vaccins autres engagements pris
l'investissement de 150 milliards
d'euros sur sept ans un soutien aux
projets voulus et porté par les
africains dit on à bruxelles
convoité aussi par les monarchies du
golfe le continent attire les
investisseurs de la région 300
entreprises émirati sont aujourd'hui
implantées en afrique elles fleurissent
dans les secteurs de l'immobilier des
communications du transport et des
énergies renouvelables
illustration avec la société a mais apa
war qui opèrent au togo est un reportage
d'emmanuel sodji emmanuel landais pour
france 24
c'est à blitta au coeur du togo là où le
réseau électrique était défaillant que
la société me rate i am et a implanté sa
première centrale solaire en afrique sur
une vingtaine d'hectares pour une
exploitation de 25 ans depuis une
dizaine de mois cinq mille panneaux
solaires suivent toute la journée la
direction du soleil via un capteur
électronique une technologie unique en
afrique de l'ouest pouvant avoir de
l'augmentation de production à peu près
10 à 20% de la production initiale près
de cent cinquante mille foyers
bénéficient ainsi de l'électricité sans
coupure pendant la journée la proximité
de la centrale et sa capacité à donner
du courant continuent à peser lourd dans
l'implantation de cette entreprise son
patron est à la tête d'une des plus
grandes sociétés de fabrication de gaz
cinq cent mille bouteilles par an pour
le marché local et l'export comme on a
su qui va aller nager en continu et le
jour et la nuit
le togo redouble d'efforts pour attirer
les investisseurs afin d'atteindre
l'accès universel à l'électricité d'ici
à 2030 et avec l'appui des fonds
d'investissement émirati les projets se
développent beaucoup plus vite de son
côté as mais bénéficie d'un site gratuit
de facilité de raccordement au réseau
électrique existant d'exonérations
fiscales et de la possibilité de
transférer ses profits à l'étranger
aujourd'hui la production d'énergie
essaie de combler le trou entre la
demande et le marché malheureusement
cette production d'énergie n'est pas
rentable parfois elle est très cher dans
certaines zones et a des effets sur
l'environnement c'est pour cela que nous
avons mis en place des initiatives comme
celle des théâtres 7 en afrique avec un
partenariat public privé dont le but est
de fournir de l'énergie propre pour 100
millions de personnes avant 2035 les
émirats arabes unis et veulent faire
partie intégrante du futur de l'afrique
le montant des investissements est
estimé à 104 milliards de dollars en
2020 l'egypte
le maroc sont en tête de liste suivie
par des pays d'afrique subsaharienne
comme le nigeria le mali ou le sénégal
la rdc devient également un partenaire
majeur avec le lancement il ya deux
semaines de la construction d'un port en
eau profonde à banana
c'est la fin du journal de l'afrique
merci à vous de votre fidélité reste
avec nous l'information continue sur
france 5
[Musique]